Chevy how did you how did you end up in
this in this film in the original film
but Harold Ramis
who was a dear friend and and had
already I believe directed me in
Caddyshack so this was his second movie
he was the director and very funny
gardener I remember shooting this one
the first shot we shot was pulling out
of the garage and bags and then I had
some lines I said to Harold how do you
want me to play this and he'll sit
brought and boy did I go abroad for and
Beverly how about you how did you end up
in the film um I went in on a meeting
you were judging me I guess it was it I
guess you would call it audition I was
married to Lorenzo at the time and I
read it and I said wait a minute I'm I'm
29 years old and supposed to be the
parents of a 15 and 16 year old and we
killed the mother and he wants to cheat
on me and there's a dead dog and but my
husband read the script and he said
Beverly Luc is very funny look at this
cousin Eddie he's a tin cleric he's
hilarious we do it so I did it was very
much a family that started then but you
know the thing about Christmas vacation
is that it's taken kind of precedence
it's like a high point in that whole
franchise so Juliet and Johnny did you
guys I mean you were the third set of
Griswold children were you aware of that
when you we were totally aware of that
in my household it was amazing because
vacation the original was legendary yeah
all of this meant so much to me because
it was as a little young teen actor this
was a big studio movie we worshiped
Chevy in my home flesh another franchise
fleshly us I mean felt way and then
Beverly D'Angelo had worked with my dad
so I was really moved by that fact and
then Johnny we play natural siblings
this guy over here mr. Khiladi was a
fully formed young man at that how old
were you then
I turned halfway through filming I
turned 14 really hey Lizzy you're
younger than me but of course I thought
I was 25 yeah and he so did everyone
else so good yeah it was the coolest 15
year old that I've ever walked the
planet damn how did you end up in this
movie you said that was a you had an
interesting story about that well I was
engaged to a doctor at the time so
spending half my time in Florida and
Shelley Winters who was my child a great
actress Shelley Winters was my
daughter's godmother and she said why
are you running away from Hollywood I
said there's no work in Hollywood for
women right now none and I'm helping
people here I'm saving lives what am i
doing in Hollywood she said you'll get
back to Hollywood you get a great part
so I came back and they said you have an
audition this week you have to go in
auditioned to play Chevy's mother I I
said I'm only about six years older than
Chevy she said you got to go so Shelley
did this she loaned me her dead mother's
dress to wear
true story I went down to Salvation Army
and got an old pair of glasses and some
Oxford's we put my hair up in a chignon
and I put talcum powder and I put it all
over my head and now I go in and as I
get there out on the sidewalk are all
these I swear to you great actresses
June Allyson and Alice Ghostly these
stars when I was in kindergarten there
were stars there were great stars and
there wasn't enough work for women I
felt horrible I swear to God
so I thought well he'll a man you were
there and you had that cat that you
didn't have what did I have the casting
director is not supposed to endorsers of
old actors looking ugly in case we're up
for a sexy part later we won't get it so
but she did it anyhow I walked in I said
so I'm not gonna say a word and I walked
in and Chevy was over there and I
thought okay I said Sonny Boy Sonny ball
my Sonny Boy with you jaws and opens
your mouth and when his side and played
games on your face
and said I love you Sonny Boy and I got
the job
[Applause]